allora io vi parlo di dna e vi faccio
dei disegni ho preferito questo che le
cose tecnologiche molto avanzate dei
miei colleghi
allora il dna è questo una doppia elica
che all'interno delle nostre cellule
miliardi di cellule e che costituisce la
base dell'umanità c'è tutto là dentro
tecnologia etica medicina arte
costruzione guai anche un sacco malattia
sofferenza
l'uomo che dobbiamo sempre tentare di
rimettere in mezzo a queste acquisti
salti tecnologici che sono spesso
vissuti come assenza del distruzione a
senza di sviluppo inquinamento
distruzione della presenza dell'uomo
dell'umanità ma che vorrei mostrarvi
anche tutti i lati positivi invece di
questa tecnologia che può essere giusto
il contrario di quello che pensate per
farvi capire quello che faccio sono
obbligata di spiegarvi farvi qualche
disegno di biologia semplice a me
servono tre cose per fare questo mettere
appunto questa tecnologia dei virus di
cui voi conoscete un esempio molto
particolare che quello il virus
dell'aids che da una malattia mortale
nell'uomo per cui non si conoscono
ancora terapie definitive e poi c'è una
cellula che contiene il dna nel nucleo
ed è una cellula malata perché questa
cellula è malata ci sono quattro
caratteri che fanno tutte le che
contengono tutte le informazioni di
questo libro
solo quattro a ttg basta che una di
queste lettere sia stata scritta male e
tutto un organismo un organo un sistema
non funziona più e tutto lo sforzo che
noi facciamo in medicina e per queste
malattie geneticamente stabilità e di
tentare di retro correggere questo
errore come se avessimo una macchina da
scrivere che possiede potessimo
cancellare questo errore e rimettere il
carattere e sano negli nel 1990 mi
sembra di parlare come le vostre nonne
nel 1944 prima guerra mondiale no
i virologi anno ci hanno dato delle
informazioni importantissime ci hanno
detto cosa c'era dentro questi virus e
perché questi virus potevano andare
dall'esterno all'interno della cellula e
integrarsi nel nei cromosomi dell'uomo
questa la caratteristica principale del
virus che produce la che che produce
l'aids l'immunodeficienza umana milioni
di persone affette da questa malattia
nel mondo milioni di persone attese una
prognosi accolto termine molto
pericolosa in africa e molti altre
regioni quando abbiamo saputo come
quando i virologi ci hanno insegnato
cose come è fatto questo virus cosa
trasporta come informazione perché
piccolissimo noi ci siamo detti
noi non io personalmente ho rubato delle
idee che venivano da campi diversi o
giusto leo giusto messi insieme per la
costruzione di un nuovo trattamento ci
siamo detti queste parti
questi elementi ridotti al minimo che
voi non vedete che ci infettano li
possiamo li possiamo demolire
biologicamente e fanne giusto dei
trasportatori dei treni come delle
navette spaziali uno dei primi oratori
ha detto come possiamo andare da mar
dalla terra armata ma e mi fa solo
spavento ma forse voi avete lo stesso
spavento che gli o di pensare di avere
l'idea di andare su marte vi provo con
lo stessa paura l'idea
che uso questo come un trasportatore
come un treno una era una navetta
spaziale e li posso mettere dentro tutta
l'informazione genetica che vogliono un
proprio tutta ma almeno quella che di
cui la natura si è sbagliata e gliele
rimento una coppia normale in modo che
questo virus perda che ha perso tutte le
sue capacità di replicazione di
produzione della malattia di
utilizzazione della cellula ai suoi fini
e li do come istruzione di portare un
informazione genetica all'interno della
cellula quindi quello che faccio è una
cosa così a pensarci è estremamente
semplice
prendo le cellule dell'individuo questo
il soggetto malato non so neanche
disegnare meglio di questo il mio
massimo questo può essere un adulto un
bambino malato e prelievo le cellule
malate queste qua le porto in
laboratorio e in laboratorio le metto
insieme a questi elementi i minimi che
sono i virus che hanno perso tutte le
loro capacità biologiche sono utilizzati
solo come navette spaziali e questi
virus vanno sono capaci ottenuto delle
loro proprietà solo la loro capacità di
andare nel nucleo e ne nucleo a vanno a
depositare nei cromosomi in un posto
quasi qualsiasi l'informazione genetica
che manca queste cellule siccome queste
sono le cellule del paziente e quindi
non sono le cellule di un donatore
completamente diverso da lui io li posso
di trapiantare a questo soggetto e
sperare di guarire della sua malattia
questo è quello che abbiamo fatto alla
fine degli anni novanta esattamente il
primo ragazzino con questa malattia è
stato curato nel 1999
allora perché vi ho detto non c'è solo
medicina c'è sofferenza c'è etica perché
la prima malattia a cui ci siamo
attaccati a una malattia mortale i
bambini nascono senza difesa
italia tutti qua dentro sapete cosa sono
i globuli bianchi
queste cellule che passano come specie
di esercito a proteggervi da tutti gli
agenti da tutti i microbi che trova che
trovano in giro nell'aria che respirate
nelle ferite che avete nel bacio che vi
scambiate con quello malato più vi sta
vicino e questi bambini invece nascono
con nessuna cellula nessun globulo
bianco muoiono nelle prime settimane che
seguono la nascita se non sono curati e
ci siamo detti se noi li correggiamo
subito appena nati queste cellule forse
abbiamo una speranza di tirarvi fuori da
una prognosi
impossibile e quello che abbiamo fatto e
nel 2000 effettivamente abbiamo potuto
rendere noto il fatto che questi bambini
condannati a vivere il tempo che si può
in dentro delle bolle di plastica delle
stanze protette in aria filtrata nessuno
li può toccare vedere baciare potevano
riuscire all'aperto con un sistema
immunitario completamente riformato ma
anche ho detto prima la medicina non
avanza così fortunatamente ho già avuto
la fortuna e o ancora la fortuna di
vivere in un periodo che posso chiamare
una specie di rivoluzione medica
rispetto alla medicina che mi hanno
insegnato tanti anni fa trenta anni fa a
padova ma subito la quello che abbiamo
scoperto due di questi bambini
qualche anno dopo anno sviluppato una
complicazione di questa malattia perché
i virus si erano messi vicino dei
informazioni genetiche pericolosissime e
hanno più il prodotto una proliferazione
non controllata di queste cellule sotto
forma di una specie di cancro delle
cellule di globuli bianchi che forse ne
avete sentito parlare si chiama leucemia
siamo ma penso c'è stato un oratore
prima di me che ha detto i ragazzi
quando sono in questi campi dove
imparano costruire del
delle macchine degli utensili dove si
servono della loro teste dei loro mani
contemporaneamente imparano più dai guai
che combinano che dagli oggetti finiti
che provocano e quello che è successo
anche a noi
nel 2000 e ci siamo fermati e nello
stesso tempo la tecnologia aveva dato
nel mondo la conoscenza di tutto il
genoma umano e quindi siamo riusciti a
capire in un tempo brevissimo con
l'aiuto della comunità internazionale
dove questi virus erano andati a
conficcarsi nelle cellule perché avevano
regolato in modo così catastrofico la la
vita di queste cellule e siamo ritornati
laboratori abbiamo di nuovo cambiato i
virus
abbiamo tolto tutte queste parti che
erano più pericolose per la
proliferazione il controllo del della
vita di un di un organismo e siamo
ritornati in clinica qualche anno dopo
dopo anni di ricerche nel 2006 e ci
siamo attaccati altre malattie genetiche
a questa alla prima che è stata il un
modello per tutto il tutta la medicina
dell'epoca perché finalmente avevamo un
prodotto la prova che potevamo
correggere il genoma in modo definitivo
questi ragazzi hanno oggi 16 15 anni e
sono il gruppo più diciamo più vecchio
dei bambini trattati per terapia
genetica nel mondo e quando vengono in
ambulatorio mi dicano ma ma perché
devono continuare a venire sto bene
rompe un po le scatole di farmi venire
non si rendono neanche conto che
dobbiamo continuare a seguire perché non
sappiamo cosa succederà domani a queste
cellule dal 2006 a oggi con il
cambiamento di questi diciamo di questi
aerei nucleari che arrivano nel cuore
delle cellula riportare un informazione
genetica corretta abbiamo corretto 3
deficit immunitari una malattia neuro
degenerativa del sistema nervoso
centrale e una malattia del globulo
rosso tutti in italia e soprattutto
in questa regione sapete che c'era una
malattia che si chiamava la talassemia
una malattia del globulo rosso bambini
anemici che devono essere trasfusi tutti
i 30 anni
i flussi migratori l'immigrazione della
gente i movimenti i viaggi gli aerei
hanno fatto che un altro anemia molto
simile a questa che in italia si chiama
anemia falciforme drepanocitosi è
diventata la malattia genetica più
frequente del mondo milioni di bambini
di uomini e donne affetti da questa
malattia nel mondo lo ms ha dichiarato
causa mondiale perché frani non ci
saranno più trasfusioni non ci sarà la
possibilità di trapiantare tutti questi
pazienti la terapia genetica è attesa
come un modo per venire venire a capo di
questi milioni di persone che muoiono
constantemente in africa ci sono la
grande maggiori maggioranza di questi
bambini muore prima di raggiungere il
quinto anno di vita perché non ci sono
transizioni perché anno la malaria nello
stesso tempo è quello che mi ha
insegnato la questo progresso della
medicina è una cosa che è molto legata
alla tecnologia
un po come mister wireless più la
tecnologia diventa complessa diventa
semplice trasportarla e diventa semplice
portarla dappertutto più diventa
personalizzata la medicina e meno
diciamo una medicina a caso che fra gli
altri effetti a quello di sollevare i
sintomi di una malattia più o meno
costosa per la società
la terapia genetica oggi costa è fatta
paziente per paziente quasi che faccio
un menù personalizzato per ogni bambino
ha per ogni adulto che tratto ma domani
questa è la
la terapia che costerà meno alla società
perché la potremo fare in ambulatorio
perché possiamo trasportarla perché
quello che dobbiamo trasportare molto
poco e tecnologicamente trasmissibile
con molta velocità
un po come il suo wireless dappertutto
nel mondo
quello che trovo un po peccato che
andiamo più veloci che i nostri
amministratori politici che i governi
che il pensiero economico perché il
pensiero economico e ristretto vede solo
oggi domani e non vede fra cinque anni
fra 10 cosa succederà delle terapie
convenzionali che costo avranno nella
società e non riescono a investire più
di soldi in questo in questi trattamenti
che invece domanico strano molto poco
avranno permetteranno un'uguaglianza
della distribuzione della sanità ha un
numero molto più importante di persone
permetterà che noi andiamo con questa
tecnologia clip che sia insegnata e
applicata della gente che vive migliaia
di chilometri lontano da qua che forse
non ha acqua che non ha il trapianto che
non sa di unità di cura intensiva di
fare di accedere a delle terapie
innovanti a basso costo e con una
preparazione che molto meno importante
di quella che le cosiddette terapie
convenzionali si fanno
ed è vero che dunque questo vorrei dirvi
la tecnologia non è solo distruzione
dell'ambiente non è produzione
esclusivamente la tecnologia e crescita
e sviluppo per tutti basta che sappiamo
portarla e distribuirla in tempo idoneo
a su tutta la superficie della terra
l'altra
l'altra cosa molto importante che ho
sentito e che mi vorrei riagganciarmi
agli altri è quello dell'arte si simona
ha detto la la danza è quello che mi
avvicina più all'amore io vi dico non
c'è un
cosa un'attività umana che vi separa
dalle cose dalle dall'amore dai
sentimenti dall'etica dal qualsiasi cosa
fate
qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi persona volete
diventare c'è sempre posto per la
creazione per l'arte per la libertà per
trasportare qualcosa di importante
altrove velocemente in poco tempo la
cosa importante è quello che ha detto
lorella la scuola c'è la solo solo punto
dove tutti possiamo diventare uguali gli
uni agli altri e la scuola i banchi di
scuola
questa scuola che sta diventando sempre
più povera mal distribuita dove le
disuguaglianze sono sempre le più forti
e quindi se oggi un messaggio da
lasciare ai giovani e meno giovani a
quelli che hanno preso il tempo di
venire qua
malgrado la tecnologia mal grandi film
visione
noi abbiamo bisogno di incontrarci
perché solo incontrandoci possiamo avere
idee creazione transporto di
informazione e che quindi nessuna
tecnologia eviterà il fatto che dobbiamo
vederci dobbiamo ispirarci puntualmente
dobbiamo cogliere da voi quello che noi
non sappiamo fare wireless in africa
vuol dire avvertire in tempo reale e
donne incinte tre pano citare che devono
prendere l'ossigeno per sopravvivere
vuol dire agli smartphone non servono
solo per i vostri sms possiamo
connettere persone nei posti più
disparati del mondo e mandargli un
messaggio secondo il livello dove sono
nella loro gravidanza per avvertirli di
fare un'azione che salverà la loro vita
in tempo reale questa e tecnologia
e se con questi quindici minuti ho
convinto 12 ragazze sedute
fra di voi a fare medicina credo che
questo è stato il mio più grosso
contributo allo sviluppo nel mondo
grazie